i thank you for your patience getting
you this video a little late couple days
late it's on a little mini vacation it
was a nice getaway but before we get
started i do want to thank the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by you
thank you for watching also i'll say
this video spoilerish going to talk
about the plot as we go through it as
always not going to be a play-by-play
but generally you should probably watch
this video after you watch the episode
also this is another reminder that [ __ ]
in the comments section is not me do not
fall for scams the house of the dragon
episode 2 largely revolves around the
king has to choose a new wife you know
which is kind of expected especially in
these times there's tension between him
and his brother damon targaryen played
by matt smith i called him adam smith i
guess
i worked with an adam smith once whom
people have said looks like viggo the
carpathian though they're not wrong i
just see kefka in my fantasy world of
this final fantasy 6 series that will
definitely never happen i constantly
mentally cast that role i cast all the
roles really lock cyan kefka and now
kefka so the king is expected to choose
a new wife this episode largely revolves
around that also the realization among
rene targaryen is like
i'm the heir as long as i'm the heir he
has a son no longer the heir the lord
valerian who i guess has the biggest
fleet his naval fleet is just
unparalleled in all the land he's the
richest house and so he's like you
should we should merge our houses you
should marry my daughter and no one will
be able to stop us and then i saw him
talking with this little girl and i was
like is that the daughter she was like
12 or some [ __ ] the king was like ah
i'm gonna go for my daughter's
girlfriend that's a westeros normal
family dynamic thing to do right there
so the big reveal is instead of marrying
lord valerian's daughter he's marrying
otto hightower's daughter the hand of
the king is one step closer in that game
of thrones damon targaryen does a power
move in this episode he's like oh my
wife's pregnant i'm stealing this egg
i'm gonna do a ritual his she wasn't
pregnant so they all go there they're
pretty much like give me back the egg
stop being a child then his dragon comes
out of nowhere and then rinera's yellow
dragon cyrax comes out of nowhere and i
was like oh it's red versus yellow baby
it didn't happen but sector and cyrax we
almost got that fight so at the end of
the episode valerian's very pissed so
he's like you know what i'm going to
team up with damon targaryen he can have
my wealth he can
what's the phrase win civilization that
that's what we call it well that's what
it felt like it felt like you have that
ally that civilization that has this
huge army you're like i'm safe for now
then you piss them off and they go ally
themselves with another civilization
that hates you and now that civilization
has well they have the ally with the
biggest army see king viserys that's his
problem you know he's making little
sculptures and stuff he's going for a
culture victory should have been going
for a military victory or at least when
there was tension between him and damon
targaryen you should have been like i
should i should put a little bit of r d
into military there are these weird crab
people by crab people i mean these
people who are taking sailors and
nailing them to posts and letting crabs
eat them i don't know where they come in
they just kind of came out of nowhere
and now we're like oh okay we're dealing
with the the crab crucifixion people
though it has jumped months this show
seems to do a lot of time jumps the
second episode picks up a few months
like half a year after the first episode
it looks like the third episode picks up
some years after the second episode
years i mean i'm not talking like 10 but
it looks like a couple my fear for the
show which is funny because in the first
episode of my previous video about this
i was like oh yeah it deals with it's
like westeros but dealing with the most
interesting house in westeros but i'm
starting to get the feeling if not fear
that this show might feel like it runs
into the danger of feeling like you're
looking at westeros through a keyhole
you look at game of thrones you had the
phrase you know you had the gray joys
you had these other families out there
granted we're only two episodes into
this show so that stuff might come in
but it made the world feel larger this
might feel like all right targaryens
kings landing i don't know but right now
i'm like well it might work i mean i
thought it would work in the sense that
yeah this is a one-off right it's just
one season and that's the book greenlit
for a season two and they might do it
for eight years we'll see i just hope
history doesn't repeat itself also and
i'm almost embarrassed to say this i
shouldn't admit this but i didn't
recognize him in the trailer didn't
recognize him and watching the first
episode i'm like i know that dude
all right gotta look it up oh my gosh
it's three seafons how did i not wow
total scene stealer man this dude is
stealing scenes if not the show he's
incredible i am intrigued as to why king
viserys is rotting seemingly from the
inside out he's got rod on his back with
pus his pinkies rotting away his hands
are in maggots like all right guys
what's the scoop today who's killing him
there is a new intro though i didn't
even talk about the new intro yeah intro
i mean first episode didn't have the
intro and then we heard second one will
have an intro different visuals than
game of thrones but it is the game of
thrones they mean
one of the greatest
theme openers of all time i do make the
argument in game of thrones it was
easier to see what the visuals meant
you're like oh these are all the
locations that we're going to in this
episode
awesome and now i'm like i think these
are all the houses that are tied to the
targaryens through blood basically a big
visual 23andme thing for the targaryens
which if i'm going conspiracy theory
here this is tinfoil hat jeremy this is
tinfoil john's coming at you i have no
proof of this but sitting on the fence
before committing is a time-honored
tradition of those who traverse the path
of uncertainty i can see them having two
different intros though with the same
visuals one had the music from the
original game of thrones the other had
the targaryen theme they were like
alright let's not have anything in the
first episode see how the audience is
feeling and then proceed accordingly
some people are still kind of unsure
alright bring in that nostalgia bait
banger bring in that intro music of
yesteryear that milkshake will bring all
the boys to the yard
i really said that my dad jokes are
getting more and more severe as i age
but i won't lie to you an intro with the
targaryen theme i'm intrigued to see
that but these first couple episodes of
house of the dragon i thought they've
been solid the tension is rising the
alliances are starting to be established
and it's looking bad for king viserys it
looks like renera targaryen's definitely
gonna have an uphill battle all right so
how's the dragon episode two have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you